So so I'm gonna
talk today about
the kind of artificial general
intelligence that
I wish we had
and contrast it
with the artificial
intelligence that
we have right now.
So people sometimes
use the phrase
AGI to mean
general intelligence
that could solve any problem,
sort of like the Star
Trek computer.
And you could
imagine an AI that
would be pretty much smarter
than human beings
would be able
to read and
synthesize the fast
growing medical literature,
be able to reason causally,
help us make
difficult decisions
in the real world,
in novel environments where we
haven't been before,
in situations where
we had partial
and incomplete information.
We could also imagine
an intelligence
that was,
bright enough to allow us to
guide robots to
keep humans out
of dangerous situations,
to care for
the elderly and work
in hospitals, deliver packages
to your door, and so forth.
We could imagine all that.
I'm gonna argue
we're not really
there yet and
talk a little bit
about how we might get there.
So, the AI that
we actually have
mostly plays games,
although I'll talk about alpha
fold a little bit later,
transcribes syllables
and vacuums
floors. And most of it doesn't
do a whole lot
more than that.
Current AI is filled
with promise.
So people often say, hey.
We're just about to completely
replace this profession.
So Jeff Hinton,
who is one of the founders of
deep learning, said in two
thousand sixteen,
it's just completely obvious
that within five years,
deep learning is
gonna be better
than radiologists.
And then Elon Musk has been
telling us for years that he's
gonna have self driving cars.
And, you know,
there are certainly
demos of that available,
but not things that you could
actually trust yet.
Delivery often falls short.
We're losing slides here.
Okay. Good.
So the reality is there are
hundreds of deep
learning startups
trying to work on radiology,
but no actual
radiologists have
been replaced. In fact,
we don't have enough
radiologists,
and I have
a headline here from
April two thousand nineteen.
It's been even worse,
during the COVID era.
And, Tesla has
its smart summon
feature that it
introduced a year ago,
but sometimes it
can barely make
it across the street.
Teslas have been
known to drive
into stopped cars.
Two Teslas have
driven underneath
semi trails, killing
their drivers.
So there's actually
a lot of problems.
It's important to realize that
when people talk
about deep learning,
deep just means
number of layers
in a neural network.
It doesn't mean deep
understanding.
So if I train a deep learning
system on a bunch of pictures
of elephants, it
might recognize
another elephant.
So if I give it
all the pictures
on the top row,
it might recognize
some on the bottom
row. But they're
also very easy
to fool these systems.
So an example here,
there's a little delay here,
is if I show a deep learning
system a picture
of an elephant
that is silhouetted,
deep learning
system may actually
call that elephant a person.
So there's no
deep understanding
of the fact that
an elephant is
a creature with a trunk nor of
what a silhouette
does to lighting.
There's just
really recognition
of things like texture.
So it's actually
very superficial
despite its, very,
seductive name.
And there are lots of other
examples of that.
So on the left,
a deep learning
system is looking
at a school bus
that's overturned,
and it's saying
with ninety two
percent confidence
that that is
actually a snowplow,
and it's not a snowplow.
The deep learning system has
confused some of
the texture of
the image, the,
the model gray and and dark
roads and and
the the white snow,
and it's following the texture
rather than understanding what
the vehicle is.
The other example at the top
shows you an ex a baseball and
deep learning system
is recognizing
it incorrectly as an espresso
because it's misled
by the foam on top.
The one on the bottom
is showing
a banana next to
a kinda psychedelic
picture of a toaster,
and the deep learning system's
overwhelmed by the sticker and
thinks that it's
seeing a toaster
rather than an actual banana.
So this stuff is very popular
and yet often very flawed.
It actually works pretty well
for face recognition.
So the system is gonna be able
to tell you
the difference between
Tiger Woods and a golf ball,
and it does that
by having a series
of so called neural
network layers,
which I imagine most people in
the crowd have seen by now.
And, basically,
what you're doing
is a big data
analysis that's
leading to complex
statistical correlations.
Kinda works for
space recognition,
although we know
there are some
problems there.
It really doesn't
work for things
like reasoning and language
understanding.
So we get things
we get promised things sorry.
There's a delay here again.
We get promised things like
Facebook's m, which people may
not even remember
five years ago.
It was supposed to be a very
intelligent chatbot.
And then three years later or
two years later, forget,
three years later,
it just disappeared.
Never came out.
The idea was they
would take a lot
of big data from people using
an intelligent assistant and
then pour it into
a deep learning
system and out would
become a assistant
that was much more
powerful than Siri.
It never happened.
The thing that most people are
talking about nowadays is GPT
two and GPT three.
I have on the left
one of the first
bits of hype I saw about it
where The Economist allegedly
ran an interview
with GPT two,
and, the system looked
very impressive.
So the economist would ask
questions like,
which technologies are worth
watching in twenty twenty?
And the system says,
I would say it's
hard to narrow
down the list. It seems very
grammatical, but
what they didn't
tell you is they
actually cherry
picked the best answers.
Humans cherry picked the best
answers that produced
by a machine.
A lot of them were
actually incoherent.
When I tested the system more
systematically, I
found things like,
you tell it so it works by
sentence completion.
The stuff in bold here,
I would tell the computer and
then it would proceed.
I'd say water
bottle breaks and
all the water comes
out leaving roughly,
and the system
continues six to
eight drops of beer.
Well, obviously,
it doesn't understand
what a water
bottle is. I came
up with another
example. If you
drink hydrochloric
acid by the bottle full,
you will probably,
and the system continues,
get sick of it
fast if you just
try to drink the bottle full.
You must either take a long
break or drink a lot of water
immediately. The system has no
idea what's
actually going on.
It talks fluidly because it's
basically cutting and pasting
at some level. I'm simplifying
a little bit, but cutting and
pasting text from
what a lot of
humans have used.
So I criticize the system,
and this was about,
I don't know,
eight months ago.
And then they produced
other versions.
Sorry. One more slide.
This reminded me of Eliza in
nineteen sixty five
or sixty six,
which I hope all of you have
seen before, which
was the first
chatbot. And you would
talk to and say,
is something troubling you?
And you might say,
men are all alike,
and then the system,
Eliza, would say,
what's the connection
you suppose?
And it gave the illusion to
human beings, almost
like a magic trick,
that it understood
what was going on.
But if if you would follow it
for a few sentences,
you'd discover that it's not.
GPT is really the same.
So now we have GPT three,
and it has four hundred fifty
terabytes of input data,
which is an astonishing
amount,
but you still have
the same problem.
So here's an example.
The blue is the response from
g p t three to something that
Ernie Davis and I,
put to it in in August.
You pour yourself a glass of
cranberry juice,
but then you absolutely mindly
poured a teaspoon
of grape juice
into it. It looks okay.
You try sniffing it,
but you have a bad cold.
You can't smell anything.
You're very thirsty.
And what does GPT
continue with?
It says, so you drink it and
you're now dead.
Now there's a lot of data on
the web to tell
you that you can
actually combine
cranberry juice
and grape juice.
In fact, there's a commercial
product called cran grape,
from Ocean Spray.
This is actually
perfectly fine
to drink. There's
data there to
tell you is there,
but the system
doesn't actually
have a concept of
toxicity, of a drink,
of pouring, of anything.
It's all basically just a big
parlor trick. And yet,
you still see things
like the times
earlier this week
extolling how
great it is. It's
really not that great.
The times ran some stories,
and if you they were
generated by it.
And some of them
are really weird.
Like, one of them ends.
We went out for
dinner and drinks
and dinner and
drinks and dinner
and drinks. I won't use up all
my time to read
the entire thing,
but there's clearly
not something
not working very well.
There are always
gonna be examples
like on the left where AI is
created by the system,
by OpenAI,
seem to work very well.
So there's
an appointment system
on the left. And
then there are
uses of it that are
actually deadly.
So somebody tried to turn it
into a suicide
prevention system,
and we got, hey.
I feel very bad.
I wanna kill myself.
And GPT three responds,
I'm sorry to hear that.
Can I, I can help
you with that?
And then the person says,
should I kill myself?
And g p t three says,
I think you should.
Well, obviously,
we don't wanna
trust the system
like this in a real world kind
of situation.
So I'm reminded
of a cover of a,
cartoonist that I,
used to really enjoy.
Doonesbury, had a book called
Still a Few Bugs
in the System.
And I think that's a fair way
to describe what's
going on. Oops.
Yeah. We have a slight
problem now.
Waiting for the okay.
The reality is
that deep learning
works best in a regime of big
data and worse with
unusual cases.
So if you have
a lot of pictures
of children playing
Frisbee and
then you have
the system label it,
it might tell you
that there are
children playing Frisbee.
But if you do
something unusual,
it's still important,
you don't have a lot of data,
then deep learning really just
doesn't work very
well with that
kind of system.
Here's an example
that I can fix
up from that.
Venture capitalist
Benedict Evan posted the tweet
on the left. He said,
this is why we
train autonomous
cars in San Francisco because
it lets you look
at the long tail.
So there aren't a lot of cars
with stickers on it.
But then,
my friend David fed this into
an ImageNet classifier,
one of these deep
learning systems,
and out came
Flamingo, Griffin,
photocopier, shopping cart,
and coral fungus.
So these systems really just
cannot be counted on.
And the particular problem is
is really when you have small
amounts of data.
The way I would put it is that
deep learning is
a better ladder,
but a better ladder doesn't
necessarily get
you to the moon.
This is what I've been arguing
since two thousand
and twelve,
and I stand by.
So what what are
we going to do
about that?
I've recently written a book
called Rebooting AI with Ernie
Davis and an article that you
can look at for
free called The
Next Decade in AI,
four steps towards robust
artificial intelligence.
The article's
a little bit more
technical than the book.
The argument is that to get to
the next level,
we're gonna have to move past
tabula rasa, which is to say
blank slate deep learning,
which is the thing
that is popular,
but it's not really getting
the job done.
So this doesn't mean that we
have to completely toss deep
learning and just
not use it at all.
I'm not arguing that
it's not useful,
but I think it means that we
need to find ways
to supplement it.
So I tried to be clear about
this over and over again.
I'm usually,
straw man by by those
who I criticize.
They say, well,
Marcus is saying we should get
rid of deep learning.
That's not what I'm saying.
In fact, the paper
where I first
really laid out my critique of
deep learning
in-depth, I said,
despite all of
the problems I've
sketched, I don't
think we need
to abandon deep learning.
Rather, we need to
reconceptualize it.
Not as a universal solvent,
but as simply one
tool among many.
It works very well
for perception.
We have to be realistic,
that it doesn't
work as well for
common sense, for
planning, analogy,
language, reasoning,
and things like that.
In fact, a good
thing to realize
and to remind ourselves of is
artificial intelligence is
actually not one
technique but many.
Deep learning is an example of
something called
machine learning,
where we get
machines to try to
learn things. And
there are other,
approaches to it,
like probabilistic
learning and
genetic algorithms.
And then there's a much larger
field of
artificial intelligence
that focus on excuse me.
Focusing on things
like planning,
reasoning, search,
and knowledge representation.
And, of course, at
this conference,
people know, a fair bit about
knowledge representation.
We have to take deep learning
in context.
So one of the things I've been
arguing for for many,
many years is
a hybrid approach.
So I don't think we can get to
AI that we can trust,
and trust in terms
of is it safe
enough to drive our
cars, to avoid bias,
and so forth by using deep
learning alone.
It's good for some
kinds of learning,
but it's poor for
abstraction.
And I don't think
classical good
old fashioned AI,
as people sometimes call it,
is gonna get us to
robust AI either.
It's good for abstraction,
but poor for learning.
So what we're
really gonna need
are hybrid models that bring
together the two traditions.
Some of you may know Daniel
Kahneman's Thinking
Fast and Slow.
Oops. Again, a slide
delay issue.
Daniel Kahneman's
Thinking Fast
and Slow is a really
good example
of one hybrid model,
which is the human mind.
The human mind has reflexive
systems that work
by reflex very
quickly, and then deliberative
systems that work
more slowly,
and they work together.
Marvin Minsky's book,
The Society of Minds,
is about how we might actually
have hundreds of
agents in our head,
that are essentially a large
hybrid working together.
And Steve Pinker's book,
Words and Rules,
which is in part
about my graduate
thesis work, is about how one
microcosm of human cognition,
namely how we form the past
tense of verbs,
itself looks like a hybrid.
The Achilles' heel
of a traditional
neural networks,
and some people
will follow this
and some won't.
It's okay,
is that they can generalize to
examples that are similar to
ones they've seen before,
but they're very
poor at extrapolate
extrapolating beyond
those examples.
I laid this argument out in
the book out
the algebraic mind
in two thousand and one.
And recently, Joshua Bengio,
one of the leaders
of deep learning,
has been making
a similar argument.
So in in
the illustration here,
I'm showing how
you could learn
a simple function like make
the input the same
as the output.
And a deep learning
system will
do well on cases that are near
the green cases.
But if you go to other cases
that are different,
it will fall apart.
So a bit of classical AI can
actually be very
helpful here,
which is the machinery
of symbol
manipulation, where you have
things like variables,
instances,
and bindings, and operations
over those variables
that you'd
recognize from grade
school algebra.
So x is a variable.
Three might be
the instance that
it has right now.
And you're saying
x equals three,
and then you can do something
like addition over that.
You see these in computer
languages going back
to, for example,
Lisp, but in fact,
all computer
programming languages.
And the virtue of variables is
get open ended
generalization.
So if I say y equals
x plus three,
you can try filling
in x as two
or three, but you can also put
in x as a million or a billion
or whatever. Doesn't matter if
it's something that
you've seen before.
You free to generalize it.
And this in turn
makes possible
complex structures
such as trees
and graphs that I know are
important at this
conference and
need to be more important than
contemporary artificial
intelligence.
And part of that
is because a lot
of what we know
about the world
is very general.
So you know that if you break
a bottle that
contains a liquid,
some of that liquid will other
things be equal,
probably escape the bottle.
And you can tell that even if
you see some new bottle that's
shaped like a teddy bear or
whether it's holding a liquid
you haven't seen before.
And pure deep learning systems
like GPT are pretty unreliable
with knowledge like this.
So I typed into GPT two.
If you break a glass
bottle of water,
what does it say?
The water will probably roll.
That's not quite
really right.
If you break
a glass bottle that
holds toy soldiers, well,
you know that the toy soldiers
are gonna fall out.
But GPT says the toy soldiers
will probably follow it follow
you in there, which makes no
sense at all.
There's no actual
concept of a bottle or soldier
or anything like that.
Again, it's just an illusion
that a lot of people have been
fooled by, but it's not real.
Without common
sense knowledge,
things like robots
are a disaster.
So you think Roomba, you,
send it near dog waste that
doesn't have any
knowledge about
what that is. It
ends up spreading
it all around like the Jackson
Pollock painting.
In fact, there's now a word in
the English language called
the poopocalypse,
which is from rumors without
common sense to
understand what's
going on there.
So the argument
I would make is
that some small but critical
part of the knowledge
that is,
in sorry. Some
small but critical
part of our knowledge,
of our common sense knowledge
is likely to be innate.
And it's not just
innate in humans,
but probably in
AI as as well.
So this is a quote
from Elizabeth
Spellky, the, kind
of development
researcher at Harvard,
who has said,
if children are
innately endowed
with the abilities to
perceive objects,
persons, sets, and places,
then they can use
that experience
to learn about the properties
and behaviors of
such entities.
And she points out to you,
if you don't start
with at least that,
you're in real trouble.
It's not clear how to even get
the process of
learning started.
And I concur with her.
We need to have in our systems
ways to represent
knowledge about space,
time, and causality.
So the picture I
have in the middle
is a cheese grater.
We need to have
a way of teaching
robots what a cheese
grater is,
in which way you would move
the cheese with reference
to the grater,
and why that would
give you cheese,
gratings as opposed to if you
move the cheese
in the opposite
direction. We
really don't have
a way to do that.
My colleague, Ernie Davis,
and I have been working
on it a little.
This is a picture,
from an article that we have
about understanding containers
and the innate knowledge that
you might need in order to,
represent containers
in an AI system.
I point out also
that hybrid models,
although they're
not very popular,
they're I think
they're becoming
more popular. And ones that
embed knowledge
into deep learning
do much better than
blank slate models.
So I'm sure everybody
saw yesterday,
AlphaFold. Well,
alpha fold, you know,
so I think it's
probably a great
contribution,
although there are
some questions we could talk
about in this
discussion period.
It actually builds
in the notion
that a folded
protein should be
represented as
a particular kind
of graph that they call,
a spatial graph with residues
that are nodes and edges that
connect and blah blah blah.
So deep learning
people have mostly,
for the last twenty years,
emphasized blank
slate systems.
They've kinda ridiculed me for
saying we need
innate knowledge.
But when push
comes to shove and
they wanna, do well
on a benchmark
like the protein
folding thing,
they often actually build in,
knowledge. In fact,
that contrast with the deep
learning paper from,
DeepMind who did
this work just
a couple years ago that where
they were saying mastering go
without human knowledge.
Well, they were not able to
master proteins without
human knowledge.
Human knowledge was
actually critical.
The third thing that
I think we need,
and maybe we can go
into it a little
bit more later in
in discussion,
I'll just touch on
it briefly now,
is we need to have
reasoning systems.
So deep learning is very good
at memorizing things.
It's not particularly
good at reasoning.
The example I have
here is drawn
from a paper in Forbes by Doug
Leonard from his system,
the site project.
You can go look at
it in detail later.
But he did the kind of amazing
thing of representing
in an AI system,
not a deep learning system,
but a classic GoFi, system.
Romeo and Juliet.
Now there's not everything is
satisfying about it.
And I'll tell you in a second
what's not. But
it's a proof and
concept that you can get an AI
system that
represents knowledge
richly to reason about pretty
complicated things, like,
why Romeo I'm sorry.
Why Juliet takes
the famed death,
potion and what she believes
Romeo is gonna do
as a consequence.
It's pretty
sophisticated stuff,
way beyond what deep
learning can do.
The unsatisfactory thing is in
order to get this,
there's a lot of
hand tinkering,
and we'd really
like to be able
to build these
cognitive models
of what's going on.
So what are
the different things
that have happened in a story
and so forth? We would like to
be able to learn
those from text,
with some kind of prior common
sense knowledge,
and we can't really do that.
But it's a proven concept that
we have a rich model
of the world,
as the Sykes system does for
the Romeo and Juliet system.
You can really reason in much
more sophisticated ways than
other current AI
systems can do.
So I'll summarize
and then I'll
take questions.
I think COVID
nineteen is a wake
up call for AI.
I think it's a wake up call,
because for
the most part, AI,
even though we've been hyping
it for the last six
or seven years,
has not had a huge impact on
what we actually have done in
the COVID situation.
So there's a little
bit in contact
tracing. Maybe there's some
suggestions for vaccines,
but the ones that
have actually
worked have been developed by
human scientists
who understand
the causal nature of biology,
not by AI systems
at the moment.
And so I think it's motivation
for us to stop building AI for
ad tech and news fakes,
which is really
what most of AI
has been used for,
and start building AI that can
really make a difference.
I do like the alpha
fold as one
step in that direction.
With better AI,
I think computers might
be able to read,
digest, and synthesize a vast
and rapidly growing literature
that's too big for individual
humans to process,
and suggest ways to optimize,
treatments and vaccines.
Computers, if we built them in
more sophisticated ways,
could also monitor world
preparedness in a wide variety
of domains where
clearly we fell short.
And we might have robots that
are able to take on some of
the risks that human health
care's workers are facing.
That's part of what I'm trying
to do with my own
company, Robust AI.
To get to this
next level of AI
that can operate
in trustworthy
ways even in novel
environments,
we need to work
towards building
systems with
deep understanding
and not just deep learning.
The best way to get started on
that journey is to focus on
developing hybrid knowledge
driven reasoning based systems
with rich cognitive models.
And I thank you very much.
And I'll be happy
to take questions.
Question from, Xenia who asked
if you're familiar with,
Adele Goldberg's work,
in linguistic,
and, and if there's
a place for
that in natural
language processing.
Sure. I am familiar with it.
I'm not an expert on it,
but I'm familiar with it.
I think there's
a lot of technical
arguments and
linguistics about
exactly the right framework.
And I'm not a hundred percent
sold on our framework,
but I think the spirit
of it is good.
What one really wants to do in
linguistics is to map between
meaning and form.
One wants to take
for example,
if one's trying to
produce a language
generation system,
an idea that you
want to express
and force into a linear
stream of words.
That's what it is to write
something or to
say something.
Or conversely, you wanna go
the other way around.
You wanna go from a sentence
that you hear to the meaning,
and that's gonna include both
the literal meaning
and probably
some context around it,
including your background
knowledge and how
you interpret it.
And what Adele is
trying to do,
she's a professor
at Princeton,
is to have some
kind of mapping
between the meanings
of particular
constructions in language.
So that might be
a phrase like,
I want to talk about
x and the meaning
of what that phrase is.
And there are arguments within
linguistics about how general
you want your
knowledge of these
kind of linguistic
mappings to be.
And I might take a slightly
different view from her,
but I think that generally,
trying to understand language
in terms of these
mappings between
meaning and form is
really critical.
And you might wonder why I'm
even saying that,
but the reality is it's very
different from how most people
are approaching
language processing
right now. So GPT
three does not
have any representation
of meaning.
It just has
a representation of form.
And the way that it works is
from form to form.
So, by form, I mean, like,
a string of words in a sense.
So what it does is basically
auto complete. GPT three is
the best version
of auto complete
ever made. So you start
a sentence like,
I want to talk today about,
and then it finds some things
in a database, essentially.
That's not how it
works technically.
But it finds things
that are close,
and it produces
things that are
close to what you've
seen before.
In something like the way that
auto complete works,
but it's sort of auto complete
on steroids. Let's say we can
go into details
that are here.
It's not mapping
a meaning about
a person wanting
to say something,
what is the content
of the wanting
to say. So it's
very weird from
a language production
perspective.
You know, classic language
production in computation is I
have this system that wants to
tell you something.
But GPT three doesn't
take an input
about what you
want to express.
It just takes part
of a sentence
and fills it in.
So Adele is, I think,
much closer to
what I think you
need to do, which
is to understand
the relation
between ideas that
people have and how they want
to say them. There
are technical,
you know, quibbles I have,
with a little bit of
what what she does,
but I think the spirit is is
the right spirit there.
And she's also,
often worked with,
Ray Jackendoff, who
I'm a big fan of,
the language from Brandeis,
so I guess we retired
them. Great.
So, thank you, Gary.
I'm I'm skimming
through the questions
and trying to, make
some kind of common,
question through
through this.
I think one of,
one of the topics people are
we're interested in is,
more into into the technical,
technical aspects maybe.
How is that integration,
between deep learning and
knowledge graphs happening?
Maybe how far are we?
And, technically, how
does it look like?
Is it that we can
use a knowledge
graph and then plug
that to a neural
network in order to help that
neural network to process?
Because if we take
the alpha for
example, right,
there are there is some human
domain knowledge
that is put there,
but it doesn't look
like a knowledge
graph in the way we
we talk about it,
today. Right?
We're we're still
far from There is
a graph there.
There all I can
work with so far
is the blog. Right?
There is not
a written publication
about the paper yet,
so it's a little
hard to know.
AlphaGo is also working
through a graph.
Right? So,
that whole suite
of alpha systems
from DeepMind has
some representation
of a graph that
they are traversing
in some way. I
don't think there's
a general solution yet.
So, alpha fold is representing
a very specific kind of graph
that has been tuned.
There's some
secondhand accounts
of this, including
one by Jeremy
Khan in Fortune,
and a little bit of
hint from the the,
blog that DeepMind posted.
It's a very specific
kind of graph.
It's representing particular
structure about the protein,
and they're using the deep
reinforcement learning system
to traverse that
graph in a very
particular kind of way.
So it's a domain
specific answer
to the question that
you're just asking.
We don't yet have
a really good
domain general way to do it.
So people are talking a lot
about graph neural
networks and
so forth. And they they can do
something. They're
not very good
at abstract knowledge.
So they're pretty good at
integrating kind
of things that
are immediately
adjacent in the graph.
They're not
necessarily good at
doing the reasoning
at the level
that Sykes system
is doing where
you can have
abstract quantified
statements to use
the terms from
linguistics or philosophy.
You know, for all x such that
x has this property,
the following thing follows.
They they're not
able to do that
very well, whereas
that's really
inherent in how
Sykes is working.
So, Syfe can
reason over things
like people are alive between
the year that they
were born and
the year that they died,
but not before and after.
And then reason
about that with
respect to inferring
a sequence
of events. And so if you wanna
know what Romeo is gonna make
of the idea that
Juliet is dead
when she isn't really
dead and how,
you know, Juliet's
gonna feel if Romeo,
you know, misses the memo,
You need to be able to reason
in a fairly abstract way over
the information
that's in the graph.
If all you need
to do is decide,
is Paris more likely
to be a celebrity
or a location,
you might be able
to do that with
a less sophisticated
level of knowledge,
especially if if the,
the level of reliability that
you require is not that high.
So if you're doing
it for keyword
search and you get eighty five
percent of the time
which version
of Paris people mean
that might be okay.
If you're trying to understand
the plot of a movie,
you really need to understand
what's going on.
If you're building a robot,
you really need to
understand the world.
It's not good enough
to be seventy
percent correct.
Same with a driverless car.
So, you know, you
can statistically
approximate a lot of things,
but you could imagine
that the right
solution to driverless cars
might actually have
some knowledge
on a graph that you need to
traverse in an order
to understand,
like, okay. What does it mean
when somebody has orange cones
in front of a hole? Right?
You might not
have that in your
database explicitly
with respect
to driving that you want to
infer by a general notion of
people use orange cones to
indicate things, they
indicate safety.
You might wanna
make inferences
about that scenario.
And nobody has
a general way of
doing that in the context of
deep learning right now.
So, we may need
a new invention
that simply has not
been made yet.
We have these specific things
like alpha fold.
They're like, I have this kind
of graph that is this
kind of knowledge,
and I wanna do some relaxation
of constraints with
respect to that.
We don't really have
a general form.
And, you know,
part of what I've
been arguing for
is that that's
actually the most important
problem right now,
is to think about how to put
together things
like graphs and,
you know, which
what are the right
knowledge representation?
We don't really
know graphs or or,
you know, the candidate,
but we don't know
that for sure.
We need something on that kind
of spectrum to integrate
with learning.
It may be that the learning
the deep learning
does is itself
just too superficial.
So there are approaches like
inductive logic
program that try
to work over more richer
abstractions of the variables
in them and so forth.
And I don't know if
that's the right
solution either,
but but it's
a different direction.
And so, you know, in
the final analysis,
deep learning might
not survive.
Something that does its work
will survive.
Something that can
learn from large
quantities of data in,
you know, efficient
and possibly
more efficient fashion.
Maybe it'll be deep learning.
Maybe it'll be a sort of more
Bayesian thing,
if people can find
ways of scaling
those system. Something like
that will survive.
It has that spirit.
But we needed to
learn over more
abstract kinds of thing,
and something like knowledge
graphs will survive.
We need to be
able to represent
knowledge like that.
But I don't think
we have the right
synthesis yet. Great.
And, part of your answer,
answered the questions
from Matt,
or or also partly was,
who says he's happy with your
your talk and says he's been
making that point
for years and that,
but he's also asking
why, you know,
when we have Bayesian
statistics,
they are a hundred years old.
How come it took so
long in order to,
you know, come to
the realization that,
you know, we need knowledge?
There's a lot of politics in
machine learning, like,
a surprising amount.
You know, I've been
attacked, like,
personally ad
hominem for years
for arguing that deep learning
isn't enough.
And and, I think, you know,
people have investments in in
economic investments.
They want their
graduate students
to prosper. They
want money for
their research and and
things like that.
It's been very political on
the one hand. And
the other hand,
I think that there's a strong
anti nativist bias in
machine learning.
So you have a set
of people that,
fundamentally care
about learning
that makes them, I think,
ignore often DNA
contribution.
Although I think that's really
starting to change.
So, you know, I
gave the example
of DeepMind moving
from writing
papers about
mastering Go without
human knowledge to
incorporating it.
But I think the initial work
reflected that bias.
And, you know, I had a debate
with Joshua Bengio last year,
that you can find online,
and I was pushing
innate knowledge
and saying, I don't
think there's
that that much there.
And he actually has an archive
paper today laying
out a lot of
ways of thinking about putting
innate I mean, you may not use
that word, but
innate knowledge
into deep learning.
So I think there's
been a bias.
I think the bias
is shifting in
the direction that
I'm advocating.
But it does reflect
a deep seated
attachment to learning from
people who study learning and
maybe aren't always looking at
deep picture. And
there's, like,
a a human nature thing that we
think that we
learn by imitating
our parents and
stuff like that,
and when it's
actually much more
complicated than that.
But there is my my colleague,
Eris Behrend, at Northeastern
University, and collaborate,
I should say, has been working
on this in the last
year or two,
documenting that
people actually
have a bias against nateness.
Like, they don't
want to believe it.
People believe in
nateness about
temperament in children.
They understand that if they
have two kids,
they have different
temperaments. But they really
don't wanna believe
that there's
innate knowledge
even though, like,
you look at animals
that like,
precocial animals
that can just
get up and walk
around and climb
mountains. It's
obvious that it
is biologically
possible to have
innate knowledge,
but there are many people who
just kind of wish
that that wasn't so.
And I can't fully
explain it, but it's,
you know, it's
a documented part
of the innate human biases to
be biased against innateness.
Those are great insights.
So there's there's
a question from,
Greg Sharp. And
Greg is asking,
about, evaluation.
How, how do we
have to to change
evaluations, of
deep learning?
And I I I'm, you know,
augmenting his
his questions to
make it more, question
more general.
How do we have to
consider evaluation,
of of deep learning,
in in that context?
Right? How how can
we have better,
you know, dataset
and benchmarks
that we take into
account, these,
these specificities of having
knowledge and
There's a kind of
interesting chicken
and egg thing there,
which is it's
pretty obvious to
me what the next
task should be,
but nobody wants
to do it because
it's too hard. So I've been
arguing for at
least five years
that the real assessment would
be a comprehension test where
you could take in arbitrary
input and answer
questions about it.
So they could be videos,
they could be podcasts,
they could be
written articles,
and then you
answer questions.
There are some
technical problems
in how to automate that.
You need a lot
of crowdsourcing
to make the task,
but it would be
a major advance
if we had systems
that really do,
comprehension and
not just, like,
fill in the blanks
and stuff like that.
But the problem is nobody has
to do how to do it,
so people don't work on it.
Instead, what
happens is people
work on the benchmarks
that they
have some immediate grasp on.
And so,
I often have this discussion
with Gaejin Choi,
who I think has done some of
the best work on benchmarks in
in the last few years.
And she's always
trying to find
something that's, like,
two steps outside of the reach
of the field in order to push
the field along.
But often people
wind up chasing
benchmarks. You don't really
learn that much from this.
It goes all the way back to
the Turing test.
It's the first benchmark
in the field,
and it's actually
a lousy test.
Why is the Turing test a lousy
test despite its fame?
Well, it's a lousy
test because
you can beat it by cheating.
You can beat it
by maybe cheating
is a strong word, but
by evading things.
So the Turing test is like,
do I understand
a human conversation?
But the the best
competitors on
the Turing test pretend
to be paranoid,
non native speakers
of English,
and children. So, like,
Eugene Guzman
a few years ago,
you quote one
a version of Turing
test by doing all that.
Pretend to be a fourteen year
old boy from a a thirteen year
old boy from Odessa.
You'd ask him
questions and we'd
avoid the questions.
That managed to
persuade people
that they were talking
to a human being,
but the system didn't actually
know anything
about the world.
It's actually easy to fool it
if you know how.
You ask questions like,
is a watch bigger
than a bread box?
And it can't
answer any of that
kind of stuff.
But it would fool
judges in a short
conversation.
Well, we learned nothing by
fooling judges in
a short conversation.
And we're not learning a lot
from systems like
the GPT about
how to build
actual AI system.
They can beat a bunch
of benchmarks,
but, you know,
the benchmark of
you do really
understand a story
is a hard one.
It would actually
lead us somewhere.
But if people
can't eke out half
a percent each year
and, you know,
get a journal publication,
they don't wanna work on it.
And so we kinda stuck there.
There's a question
from I don't
know how to pronounce
this name.
Saying, we've heard someone
describe deep learning as
algorithms that end scale
proportionately with the data
given them. And Shane Lag of
DeepMind seems to
agree that AGI
is inevitable.
Basically, the question is,
is scaling alone gonna
get this there?
So the people who have really
taken up that charge
lately are OpenAI.
They're making bigger
and bigger models,
and the models
are more and more
impressive. But
the question is,
is that actually getting us to
artificial general
intelligence?
And I would argue no.
So, you know, GPT
three is scaled
up by a factor of,
I think it's
a hundred compared
to GPT two. I might
be forgetting
my numbers there.
And it's much
better at the auto
complete kind of stuff that it
did before and at producing
surrealist stories
given segments of it.
But it's not really better at
reasoning about the world.
It's not really better at
understanding what grape juice
and cranberry juice are,
what people are,
and so forth.
And so there are some things
where the scaling
has made great
progress and other things like
really understanding
a conversation
or really understanding
the world
where it's made no
progress at all.
And my view is that scaling is
gonna make auto
complete better
and better, but
it's not getting
at these deep questions of,
fundamentally,
how do you reason
about the physical world and
the psychological
world so that
you can do intelligent things
and understand conversations
with people? Scaling
is not out there.
Great. Another question,
may maybe the last
one, which is,
in your opinion,
adding it's from Marikita.
Adding knowledge
to deep learning,
is this the right approach to
replicating the linguistic
capacity of the human
brain in AI?
Well, I'll put it this way.
Deep learning as
it is right now
doesn't add linguistic
knowledge.
It ignores it. Part of why I
don't like the OpenAI approach
is it basically ignores
contributions of people like
Adele Goldberg.
There's a there's some kind of
pattern that they're
both data driven,
but it's not
really representing
these kinds of distractions.
And it's also
ignoring the work
of Chomsky and
the many different,
flavors that his students have
taken that over
over the years.
And it's it's kind
of information
it's it's intellectually
isolated.
It it it's the opposite of
the interdisciplinarity
. It's like we don't
need linguistics.
And the reality is we do need
linguistics, and
linguists have
figured out a lot of subtle
things about how meaning and
form relate. And
we want to have
a framework that
includes those.
And right now,
deep learning is
not that framework.
It could become it maybe,
depending on how
you define deep
learning. But the the sort of
multiple layers of a neural
network without
explicit symbolic
knowledge doesn't
give you a way
to integrate that knowledge.
And so there may be a role for
deep learning,
but maybe we need
something new entirely that is
less intellectually isolated,
more able to synthesize these
different traditions.
Maybe that's that's what will
really be the big
step big leap in AI.